never before have you faced anything so
strange and sinister so bizarre and
unnerving until okay movie review time
doing kind of a classic horror movie
that maybe is not as well-known as some
other yeah that's a good scare to show
me when I was a kid two Cronenberg flick
called the brood and of course it's got
ol Oliver Reed in it and that dude he
always scared me you know he just seemed
like he was like one drink away from
whipping your ass yeah I'll stay on the
edge because I think you mentioned that
to you in our review on burnt-offerings
yeah you mentioned how much he
frightened dance yeah when I was a kid I
was scared to death that guy yeah which
is very funny because everyone that's
worked with him I mean obviously he was
an alcoholic and one who was drunk he
you know did various shenanigans and get
arrested or whatnot he was funny
evidently but yeah but everyone said
when he was sober and when he was
working and stuff like that he was
actually a very personable very funny
very gently so it is it's funny to me
but I can see exactly what you're saying
he does seem like in every movie that
he's in even when he's playing a
sympathetic character like he didn't
burnt-offerings he's even kind of
sympathetic in this one even though he's
marginally a bad guy but what he's
responsible for all this [ __ ] right but
he does seem to own that so you know
that's kind of makes him sympathetic in
that way but a lot of his characters do
kind of come across as teetering on the
brink of sanity for all time yeah what's
funny though I found out he was only
like 40 to 41 during this time where
they live they live fast and you know I
know it's hard Beca that tells me
because we have we have The Criterion
Collection blu-ray brood which looks
fantastic and one of the extras on it is
a very amusing segment from the old Merv
Griffin Show yeah it had Oliver Reed on
it Orson Welles and Charo it's our
people Carlos
she's adorable yeah she doesn't talk
much in this one cuz it's mostly Oliver
Reed talking and talking [ __ ] with Orson
Welles but the second that Oliver Reed
said that he was 42 yeah I was like
really I was like wow that's three years
younger than me and he looked
yeah it looks considerably old yeah
people age faster back dad well it was
all the drinkin and yeah even look at
like look at that Expendables 3 all
right you got Stallone his privates 71
in that flick and he looks awesome for
71 you'd never know that you put that
against a 71 year old you know the
average 71 year older today and you're
like it's night and day
you know I mean but I guess technology
technology and health awareness yeah I
definitely do think people back in the
day didn't really take care of their
health
no the way people do nowadays because I
do feel like people are of our
generation I mean we know people in
their 40s and 50s that grew up in the
same that look young still yeah you know
that you would never run that you would
never know how old they were yeah
whereas you know when I look at pictures
of people who were in their 30s and 40s
or even see in movies like actors and
stuff who you would presume would look
you know better than regular people yeah
you see them in movies they're in their
30s and 40s they all looked old though
they're pretty old yeah anyway let's get
back to the movie I mean um this is a
cool flicked about basically about a guy
who's he's breaking up with his wife his
wife it's kind of like in this cult it's
not really a cult it's but but it's run
like a cult it's what was it called it
was something about the psycho plasmic
yeah which might be something Kyle it's
kind of like therapy like psychological
therapy for mentally disturbed people
and kind of has some cult like almost
Scientology level I don't know kind of
like ot mind powers yeah involved with
this and why this is in this movies
because Magnusson late 60s and in the
70s that middle class lifestyle really
started to kick in with the single
income families the wives were like
stay-at-home wives they lived pretty
good lives and they started to develop
you know like white people problems
neuroses yeah it started
like firstworldproblems so it was kind
of like a hip thing to do back in the
70s to get involved with these like
self-exploration self-development you
know I need a mentor I needed it I need
a daddy programs is kind of what they
were and that's why this is in this
movie you know I mean it kind of
kronenberg's kind of the kind of show
he's trying to show you kind of how
weird that stuff is and then maybe
there's some sighs maybe there's some
scientific plausibility for something
kind of paranormal to go on and in these
programs yeah I mean one thing that
Cronenberg what kind of one of his pet
themes and this was actually I kind of
consider this I mean the brood came out
of 1979 I consider this his first great
film it's good film he had done you know
some kind of independent shorter films
crimes of the future and stuff like that
he had made rabid he had made shivers he
made up like a car racing drama called
Fast Company before this one and
actually he the next film he was
supposed to do after Fast Company was
supposed to be called the sensitives
that was the script he was working on
now that would later become scanners but
because circumstances in his own life
intervened he actually wrote the brood
first and wanted to work on that first
because I don't know if you guys know
but David Cronenberg was going through a
very very nasty divorce when this movie
was written that involved a very bitter
custody battle the mother of his child
was going to take the kid and like go
off and live with these quote/unquote
nice people which is implied that she
was gonna go live in a cult with the kid
and David Cronenberg did not want that
to happen yes so he was going through a
lot of emotional turmoil
so the brood was kind of like a personal
film for him because it revered what was
going on in his own life and he has some
say jokingly or glibly referred to the
brood as this was my version of Kramer
vs Kramer but more realistic which which
I don't think that's a globe at all I
think that's actually quite accurate
because as
a as an examination of like the
breakdown of a marriage and things like
that this is actually a lot more I mean
it's very nasty it's very so in a way I
do think it's a lot more realistic than
Kramer versus Kramer which Fe I found a
little bit schmaltzy but um this is a
disturbing movie for sure but like I
said I think this is his first great
movie because it has that kind of
cerebral art house aesthetic that he got
known for in later years but it also has
a little bit of that grindhouse sleazy
yeah like a touch of that also but he's
kind of examining I think sort of the
germ for this too was that he was
examining how people's neuroses and
psychological problems could manifest
themselves in physical form
raaah much the way like stigmata or like
or like stress would cause an ulcer or
poltergeist yeah or something like that
but taken to a logical extreme but also
a very over-the-top yeah he's gonna get
into like body horror yeah who's gonna
take that into like body horror also
alright can the power of the mind
actually caused a body to do certain
things right which we wish you know we
don't want to spoil everything about
this movie because we're assuming that
people in our audience haven't seen this
now I don't know if you can see it for
free online you might be able to see it
if it's if it's if you could see it for
free would probably be on dailymotion
but it's an expensive blu-ray yeah well
all of the criterion collection well
it's because they're I mean they have a
lot of nice stuff on them they've been
they've been updated they do a good job
restoring it you bring the audio and
even the other blu-rays they're about
the same price as a criterium yeah yeah
you could probably get it cheaper on DVD
but this doesn't what this one's worth
watching so it's really neat and they
Cronenberg breaks a lot of rules in this
like you have well weird children you
know killing adults in front of other
children at school and just weird stuff
like that it's very disturbing it's very
disturbing children killing adults and
then you find out that these children
there's something wrong with these
children and it's not really the Village
of the Damned it's a lot worse than that
yeah in a way think the kids aren't
normal
it has to do with psycho plasmic s-- i
don't know if we should spoil all that
but Oliver Reed did it yeah well he
plays the head of this institution like
I said David Cronenberg another one of
his pet themes is institutions pseudo
scientific institutions that take away
people's identities or to you know or do
various kind of body horror type of
things you know mess up people's natural
proclivities and he's very into that and
this is another one where you know this
society the soma free Institute is what
it's called and Oliver Reed plays a
well-respected psychotherapist named Hal
Raglan and he's the head of this it's
essentially a private clinic yeah where
people check themselves in and he does
this sort of it's almost like theatrical
role playing later he puts himself in a
role of whoever has caused the patient's
neuroses yeah and he tries to get them
to like role playing yeah versal he
tries to get them to like act out their
antagonism toward him and hopefully it
will manifest itself in a physical form
which I they don't state this out right
I don't think but I think it's implied
that he wants it to come out as a
physical form so that it can be expunged
right so you can get over it you can get
through like it's gone like it's seeped
out of your very pores and what's weird
is you have like adult men calling him
daddy and it's it's very uncomfortable
make your skin crawl you know through
parts of it you know they're talking
about child abuse and child neglect and
it's the first like 1/8 of the movie the
first couple scenes they're you
Cronenberg's really just trying to get
underneath your skin which he does very
effectively just like Cronenberg is very
good at that super cringy yes he's doing
it on purpose he's just trying to cranny
the [ __ ] out and that sets the stage for
this and also what I wanted nothing that
I liked about it is the instant
to itself it's out in the country and it
part of it looks like a bunch of cabins
yeah and then part of it looks like like
a high-tech office somewhere out
California or something like some
Silicon Valley but you get the feeling
that it's that you're secluded away from
everything else which kind of like adds
to the alienation almost kind of like
Camp Crystal Lake or kind of like the
Overlook Hotel where you're a Yin from
everything else I also like that they
set it in the middle of I mean it's
filmed in Toronto like most of his
movies are I also like that they set it
right in the middle of winter
everything's very bleak and everything
white it's just us everything is these
very sterile cold landscapes which like
I said he does that a lot in his movies
and I think that really and contrasting
with the scary children who wear these
very brightly colored little job footie
pajamas and little coats and things like
that so it's you know it's this really
cool like I really like the this weird
like sterile aesthetic of it like
intercut with these bright colors of
these little little kids it reminds me
actually and after I read some other
reviews of it I saw that I wasn't the
only person that thought this the way
that the little kids look in the little
bright colored coats it reminded me of
don't look now the horror movie with
Donald Sutherland Nicolas Roeg it's his
movie yet because that was the same kind
of things like a little kid in a red
coat and it was a similar kind of kind
of thing and that came out in 1973 I
actually want to do a review on that too
because those are my favorite movies but
um but I think he's actually paying
homage to that because there's scenes in
it that are very very similar to the
last part of Don't Look Now so I think
that that was deliberate but this movie
one of the best things about it I have
to say is I mean this was kind of his
highest budget movie at the time he had
already had a couple of hits so you know
this was kind of back in the days when
in Canada they had like a tax shelter
thing that encouraged private businesses
to invest and the arts and invest in
movies a good idea which is actually a
good idea and I kind of wish they would
do that more other places but but they
did that a lot back in the day so he got
a lot of funding from that so he
actually this cost about
1.5 million Canadian dollars at the time
to make so he could actually hire Oliver
read it was a big star Samantha Eggar
who was also a very big star at the time
although she had never done horror
before she was actually only on set for
four days they filmed all her stuff in a
very compressed I mean cuz this was a
pre still fairly small budget film and
the court was only seven people has a
good feel to it though but yeah mixture
of a high quality low-budget film that
was kind of well crafted you could yes
it was not like a schlock film where the
girl definitely not you know Cronenberg
cared about like I said as much as I
liked as much as I loved rabid and
shivers there's just early films I
haven't seen Fast Company that's not a
horror movie but um but this one like I
said seemed to where this was where he
really came into his own and you could
tell this guy is a genius and he's going
places just the whole thing about the
way it's shot and everything but I was
gonna say that Samantha Eggar she was
kind to me she was like I mean Oliver
Reed is great in this Samantha Eggar is
she's kind of like the creepy heart of
this movie like just the way her eyes
her eyes like the whites of them are so
white and like you know what I mean
she's just so eerie but kind of
sympathetic to because she's mentally
ill she's a victim also but then she's
also kind of a monster so it's it's this
really weird like balancing act and I
and I like that they did that in this
movie that everyone is still kind of
sympathetic even if they've you know
even Oliver Reid's character Hal Raglan
even though he's responsible for a lot
of the horrible things that happen he's
still a sympathetic character he's still
a likeable character he's not portrayed
as like a cackling mad scientist or
anything like that no he's not evil no
like you know it was just kind of like
the horror of misplaced intentions and
maybe he took things farther than he
should have when something you know went
in an interesting direction he pursued
it when maybe he should have stopped
right you know doing that before it got
to that level
but he's not a bad person yes eyeko
plasmic sit with psycho plasma it was
called the Institute of psycho plasma
cells called no the the place was called
the soma free soma free which I wonder
if
if that's how this Huxley ran some a
free Institute of plasma the cycle I
think which is called yes soma free
Institute of psycho psycho plasmic was
the thing that this psychotherapist
invented yeah this particular therapy
method that he was using trying to get
these like I said trying to make a
physical manifestation of you know and
in the book and in the movie he's
written a book called the shape of Rage
yeah which is kind of like was
supposedly a best-seller and everything
like that I liked about it when they
showed the Institute you know they're
all all the students are there I guess
they're not students I guess they're all
the patients patients coming out of the
Institute they're all going to the bus
remember yeah outside and just the the
way that that looked that 70s late
seventies early eighties aesthetic IRA
as a kid I remember things looking like
that yeah and the people and everything
there's always kind of like took me back
to those days and the the eeriness of
some of the things that we had during
those days like you know especially with
like mountain poltergeists and stuff
like that just look there's a lot as a
weird time to lift through that yeah as
a weird time for movies Society was in a
weird transition and we were kids yeah
that's part of it I think and I think
some of that might have been I mean some
of that might have just been the
seventies aesthetic but some of that
might have been deliberate too because
if you look at like the interiors of the
soma free Institute and things like that
it's very you know it's its greatest
aerial it's all wood panels if like that
but then when you go in to say like
candy the little girl who's kind of the
source of the custody battle between you
know the the man and wife who are
separating when you go to her
grandmother's house it's just just this
riot of like patterned wallpaper and
like all these different patterns and
it's very you know visually confusing
it's visually so I don't know if he did
that on purpose or if that was just
happened to be where they were shooting
and that's what the house looked like
but I do remember houses looking like
that in the 70s with that horrible ugly
wallpaper and just flashing with all
these other patterns and colors going on
and the furniture and stuff yeah I'm
kind of frustrated that I can't say more
about this movie because I really is
supposed to be spoiler free
you know it's kind of not really ERISA
not really review but a retrospective
and a recommendation to our audience
that yeah yeah good one well I'm only if
they know too much you're kind of taking
this movies mojo away from it yeah it's
better if you just kind of see it roll
with it and let it take you down that
direction and you're like oh okay this
is yeah I always have frustrated when we
do is maybe yeah because especially for
a movie as old as this it's like I know
I can't assume that everyone has seen it
especially ones that art you know is
well-known maybe yeah like I would
assume people had seen like say video
drum if we're just talking about Poorna
Berg movies but maybe not the brood
because it's like slightly less similar
to video dramas in this certain feel the
theme of it it's not quite as Extreme as
as video drum but I kinda like it yeah
and vibe well the thing that creeps me
out i think that brood i find the brood
scarier than Videodrome it's more a
straight horror flick whereas Videodrome
has a lot of sci-fi yeah element truth
the brood is almost like like I said
it's almost like an arc House version of
a grind house yeah movie but then again
it has a very don't look now kind of
subtle ratcheting up of the attention a
lot of the scenes are especially with
the little children and stuff like that
are really creepy they don't really show
them much it's very subtle with
suggestion so when there are scenes that
are just like really disturbing and
off-putting like if the one at the end
which I'm not going to say what it is
but you know so it has that much more
impact yeah
plus I do feel like you get really
invested in the characters and I have to
give a shout out here to um Cindy Hines
who plays the little girl candy in the
movie she actually this might have been
her first film she had done commercials
and things before this and she was in a
couple more horror movies and then she
retired from acting when she was a
teenager because she just wanted to
pursue other things there was actually
an interview with her and art Hindle who
plays the main guy
this and they kind of went back to the
school where it was filmed and she's you
know she's all grown up now obviously
but she was talking about what a fun
experience it was I think she was great
in this
she is really I mean because so much of
her role I mean this kid goes through
some [ __ ] in this book like she sees
things that no child should ever have to
see ever and you can just see the horror
and the trauma like on her face yeah but
but then she's kind of like trying to
remain stoic and all this other stuff
but then at the end you know when
everything goes to [ __ ] and everything
like that just heard freaking out and so
it's just so realistic yeah and it has
kind of an open ending it has an
open-ended ending yeah where the so girl
might fall victim to this phenomenon
also yeah yeah they do leave that open
so yeah it is kind of a disturbing a
disturbing ending in that you just but
it might because this whole thing is
kind of about repeating the cycle
like I said child abuse alcoholism is
like that so a lot of that and Oliver
Reed one drink away from whipping your
ass yeah but yeah definitely if if
you're into Cronenberg like if you know
who Cronenberg is obviously and you've
seen some of his other movies this kind
of theme will be very familiar to you
but as I said I really feel like and
I've seen most of his movies over the
years this movie is kind of his most
personal one I mean this was something
that obviously something was actually
going on in his life that he needed to
exercise yeah so it almost feels like
the perfect marriage of like [ __ ] that
was going on in his life and [ __ ] that
was going on in the movie but also the
movies kind of commenting back on what
was going on in his life because he was
trying to get these demons out via the
movie and then the people in the movie
or trying to get demons out rah via a
weird like physicality type of thing so
it was almost like this weird feed
feedback loop so I do think this was
probably his most personal yeah movie
yeah and I would take this retrospective
that we're doing now as kind of like a
cross between a tease and an analysis it
may make more sense after you watch the
movie well everything everything does
it's pretty it's quite cool yeah it's
it's easily I think Dead Ringers is
probably my favorite Cronenberg movie I
think the brood is probably oh it's hard
to say because I haven't seen I've seen
some of his more recent ones but I've
only seen them once so I'd be like Dead
Ringers Videodrome the brood that so
it's top three I put it there with like
video drummond and the hand well that's
not a crime I know
Cronenberg aside I'm just talk about
what kind of movies to put it way they
make me feel yeah about like the hand or
Videodrome or yeah I just remember we
because I I had seen this I mean I saw
it a long time ago when I was a kid and
then we then I saw it again probably two
or three years ago yeah and then we
watched it again before we did this
review and you were really you were
pretty creeped out still like yeah by
the brood yeah it has some very
unsettling it's very cringy it makes you
uncomfortable
cringy it's just an experience you know
I mean it's Cronenberg being Cronenberg
that's how he's gonna roll yeah I
remember you know watching it like for
the first time because either play this
on on cable all the time yeah the kid
first how first time I saw it was like
where is this movie taking me and then
I'm like wow it's going this way Wow is
there doing this weird and then you know
I've seen it that hundred times you know
as a kid and didn't really fully
understand it I think until I got older
yeah but it was just a weird flick you
know it's one of those ones that just
gives you even if you don't even if
you're a kid you don't entirely know
what's going on it just gives you those
really yeah kind of yeah you know what I
mean but that's why it's good too
because you know I've been watching
horror movies since I was little and I
and I love them back then even though
maybe I didn't understand all the
subtext or what was going on or anything
like that but that's why I think it's
good to revisit them yeah you know when
you're older so you can kind of be like
you can you can assume
or to adultcon and you can develop a new
appreciation for them and I think that
we've really been doing that kind of
revisiting a lot of things horror movies
that we liked as kids and then you're
seeing them again now and now you see so
much more in them yeah then you did at
the time yeah so definitely I definitely
recommend the brood it's a really really
good and a little bit underrated I think
horror movie from 1979 so check it out
if you haven't seen it already yeah we
have no idea what it looks like if you
were to see it on dailymotion or YouTube
we don't know what the transfers like
probably looks like crap on DVD but
seeing it on blu-ray it looked really
good
yeah the blu-ray looks really nice so
who oh I was gonna say it better for
being criterion collection yeah you know
they're they have a good reputation
right we're making the movies look good
so remember if you liked the show
remember to Like share subscribe on all
your social media if you'd like to
support the show check out our patreon
page at patreon.com slash 13 o'clock or
go to our blog which is 13 o'clock
podcast WordPress com and there's a link
in the sidebar to a PayPal account if
you'd like to make a one-time donation
and be sure to tune in for our regular
episodes which come out every Tuesday
and our movie reviews which come out
every Friday and until next time bye